PETE LEPAGE: We're
going to start now
talking about what I think
is the most critical part
of progressive web apps.
And that's really the ability
to make them reliable and fast,
because instead of having
to go to the network
to get the resources
that your app needs,
they can get it from
the local device,
from the service worker.
So my name is Pete.
Well, I guess I'll start here.
My name is Pete.
I'm a Developer Advocate
on the Chrome team.
I work in the New York office,
and really excited to be here.
This is my first time
in China and I've
loved every minute of it.
So thank you for having us.
And I hope that this is
useful for you and you get
to learn some neat new things.
So I want to start with
a little bit of a story.
Let's say that I'm at a park,
and while I'm at a park,
living in New York
City, I'm coming along
and I think, wow, hey,
I really like this song
that I'm humming.
And I want to record it
so that I can try it later
on my guitar.
And so I open up
my phone and I say,
OK, I'm going to go record it.
I click on the little
Voice Memo app up there.
And the Voice Memo app
opens, and wah wah,
it doesn't work, Right I
get the offline dinosaur.
Well, unfortunately,
this park is
in a cell phone dead zone
where anything on the web
just doesn't work.
Even some native apps
aren't going to work.
I can't get phone calls
or anything like that.
And this happens in more than
just a park in New York City,
right?
This happens in places
in a subway in New York,
or anywhere you
can imagine where
you don't have a good, solid,
reliable network connection.
And unfortunately, users
expect their experiences
to work reliably.
They don't care if
they're in a subway.
they're somewhere else.
They expect their
experience to always work.
And we want to fix that.
And this isn't always about
the idea of a no connection
scenario.
Maybe you're on an airplane
or you're in that dead zone.
There's also that wonderful
thing that we call Lie-Fi,
because it's lying to you.
It says, I have a
network connection.
But it doesn't.
So it thinks, oh, I'm connected.
I'm going to get something.
I'm going to work.
And it just sits there,
and it spins and it spins
and it spins.
So because of this,
we want to make sure
that pages work even if
they're not connected.
This is one of
those things, even
if you have four bars on your
phone where it is connected,
you might not have
that live connection.
So in order to become reliable--
which is a key point of
progressive web apps,
is that they are reliable--
we need instant
loading and offline.
And we need that to come
to the website platform.
So Dion mentioned
this earlier today,
and I want to repeat
it again because I
think it's really important.
If a user looks at a page,
and after three seconds
it hasn't loaded,
they're going to leave.
So you're losing
53% of your users
if they haven't seen
something in three seconds.
That's pretty drastic.
And on top of that, we know
that worldwide, that over 60%
of mobile connections are 2G.
Now many of us live in a big
city, and we're used to LTE.
We have a fast
connection at home.
Yay, that's awesome.
But not everybody has a
fast LTE connection or a 4G.
60% have a 2G connection.
And so we need to stop
relying on the network
and take that piece out so that
we can become more reliable.
Now the key feature that we
need for this is something
called service workers.
It's a relatively
new technology.
It's a spec from the
W3C, and it allows
us to go and have these
fast, reliable connections.
Now who here has heard, or
had heard of service workers
before today?
Put your hand up.
OK.
Now who here has heard of
service workers since today?
All right.
Cool.
Sorry.
OK.
So a service worker, as
Dion mentioned earlier,
is really sort of a client
side JavaScript proxy
that sits on your phone.
So it's a programmable
network proxy
that allows you to choose
how you want things to work.
But it's also more than that.
When a page registers
the service worker,
it sets up a bunch
of event handlers.
So it listens for
different events,
for things like
network requests,
push messages, updates to the
service worker, and so on.
And because it's event-based,
it doesn't take up
any system resources.
It's not sitting in memory.
It's not doing anything.
It's not using your CPU.
It's just hanging
out, chilling--
until it gets a notification,
or until it gets an event.
And then it wakes up.
So I'll say it again because I
think this is really important.
It's not consuming any resources
unless it's been woken up
to handle one of the events.
In fact, even if the
browser is closed,
so you don't have
your browser open,
it can still be woken up
by the operating system.
We're no longer
limited to a model
where the app has to be open
in order to be functional.
You don't have to have
a tab open in order
for it to be useful.
So this is important because
it adds that app-like lifecycle
to your app.
It means that our web apps can
become much more functional
and much more useful.
So when a service worker is
first registered, it fires an.
Install event and that install
event can be used to do things
like pre-fetching a
bunch of resources--
your CSS, JavaScript,
images, HTML--
anything like that, and
stores it on the device,
caches it locally so that
the next time we need it,
we can pull it right from the
device instead of the network.
Think of it as an
install-as-you-go process.
In effect, we're running a
scriptable install process
much like a native app does.
But there's no bulky zip files.
There's no need
for a store that we
need to go upload our
stuff to, and have somebody
go, yup, we approve this.
Oh, we don't approve this.
It just goes up on the web.
And we have file level
control over what is cached.
So we can say, oh, hey, I
need to update this one file.
We changed our logo.
Or maybe it's the holidays
or it's something.
We changed one
color on one thing.
We only need to
update that one file.
We don't need to update
the entire thing.
Then, once the service
worker has been activated,
we now have full
control over the way
that the system services
your app's resources.
We can look at the network
requests and see what they are.
We can go to the network and
get a file and return that.
Or we can get something
from the cache
that we've already cached.
Or we can make something up.
It's kind of cool we have
full control over how this all
works.
And all of this is
transparent to the user.
They don't see anything.
The web just works
beautifully and magically
like they're used to it working.
In fact, a well-constructed
service worker
can function as a very
smart caching system
and be entirely transparent
to the rest of your app.
It's just a
progressive enhancement
to the network and cache.
Gives you the ability
to choose smarter
ways to respond to requests.
And the big thing is it
makes our apps reliable
because they don't have
to depend on the network.
All right.
So on the topic
of service workers
are a progressive enhancement,
service workers really
are for that second load,
because the first time the user
comes to your site, the
service worker isn't installed.
It needs to get installed.
So that first time,
it's going to be
just going through, going to the
network to get all that stuff.
The service worker really
comes into play the second time
a user comes to your site,
or once the user refreshes
the page.
So let's dive in and take a
look at what the lifecycle
of a service worker looks like.
They translated
our slides for us.
So I hope that says
service worker lifecycle,
but I'm not really sure.
So when the user first
comes to the page,
it registers a service
worker with a specific scope.
Now I'll talk about
scopes in a few minutes.
But for now, think of a
scope as the set of pages
that the service worker
is going to handle.
So first thing that happens
is an install event fires,
and our service worker goes, oh,
hey, I've got an install event.
And it runs that code.
Then the service
worker goes idle.
It just sits there quietly
because, like I said,
it's for that second request.
So now the service worker
is there but it's idle.
It's just hanging out
not doing anything.
So now the second time that
the user comes to the page--
so they've come to the page, and
immediately the service worker
goes, oh, hello, I'm awake.
Let me help you with
whatever you need.
So then the service
worker is ready to handle
all of the events.
At the same time, the browser
makes an asynchronous request
to the server to see if
the service worker has been
updated, because we always
want to have the latest service
worker.
Now in this case, we're going
to just say that the service
worker hasn't been updated.
It's still the same.
Nothing's changed.
It's still the same
service worker.
And so that's it.
The service worker is activated.
It responds to any events.
Now once the service worker
has handled all the requests,
maybe the user closes the page.
Well, the service
worker goes to idle.
So it was, oh, hey, oh.
And then it goes to idle, and
finally, it goes to terminated.
It comes out of memory, so
it's not doing anything.
It's not taking
up any resources.
But it's ready to wake
up or spin up again
if any other events come in.
All right.
So let's talk about
how you update
a service worker, how the
service worker gets updated.
So much like before, the
user goes to the page,
service worker goes, oh,
hello, I'm activated,
and it starts
responding to events.
And immediately, again, the
browser checks and says,
hey, is there an update for me?
Has this service worker changed?
And this time, because
the service worker
has been updated, we
go to an install event
and an idle event.
But I want to point
out one thing here.
There are now two service
workers installed.
There's this one here.
And notice it's idle.
And there's this one
here that's activated.
So there are now two
service workers installed.
And this is important
because what
if we've changed something
major in our service worker,
but the user still has the page
is loaded with the old content?
So this one immediately goes
to idle and just sits there
and hangs out quietly.
Doesn't do anything.
And the other one keeps
handling any requests.
Now you can tell that
second service worker
to take control
immediately if you want.
And with two APIs, one called
self.skipwaiting and the other
with self.client.claim.
But you should use
those cautiously.
So now this is one of those
things that will bite you
in the bum, to put it mildly.
It's gotten me in trouble
sometimes because you
have a service worker,
and you go update it
in your development, and
you're like oh, hey, all right.
So I made this change.
Well, why isn't my new
service worker running?
Well, because you still
have a window open.
And that other
service worker will
stay in idle until all
of the windows close,
until all of the
other browser windows
using it have been terminated.
So enough theory, because theory
is kind of boring sometimes.
Let's take a look
at how we actually
would implement our own service
worker and make this work.
So first thing we need to do
is register our service worker
on our page.
So in your HTML,
we're going to say,
if service worker in navigator.
So that does the check to see
if service workers are supported
in the browser that the
user is currently on,
so Firefox, Chrome, there's
a couple other browsers that
have support for it.
We only want to call this
if the browser supports it.
So check to see
if it's supported,
because it's a
progressive enhancement.
And then we call
navigator.servic
eworker.register, and we give
it a link to the location
where our JavaScript
service worker lives.
Then we can say, hey,
you're registered.
Or if not, if there was a
problem, we'll go from there.
Next we need to handle
the install event,
that one bit where we're
going to say, oh, hey,
I've been installed.
I maybe want to go
pre-cache some things.
s So this is fired
after the service worker
has been downloaded
and has been parsed.
So let's start with
something basic.
I've got
self.addEventListener install.
And this is just
a very simple one.
It doesn't take
control of the page
immediately because it will wait
until the other things come in.
But if we want it to
take control immediately,
we want that service worker
to be in immediate control,
we can do this,
returnself.skipwaiting.
That says to the
service worker, hey you,
I want you in control right now.
And that wakes that
service worker up.
So we're going to use the
install event to pre-fetch
the resources that we need and
cache them in our local cache.
So that way they're always
there and available for us
so that they can be loaded
instantly and reliably.
In effect, this
Install Event Handler
is your opportunity to have a
fully scripted install process.
Like I said earlier,
just like a native app.
So here I've updated
my install process,
and I say caches.opencachename.
So I want to open,
a particular cache
and I want to do it
with a cache name
because I want to version the
files that I have in case I've
got multiple different things
or I'm going to change something
later.
Having a version system
is really important,
so I'm going to open
the cache and then I'm
going to say,
returncache.addall.
And I'm going to give
it an array of files
that I want it to
go grab and cache.
So I'm just going
to say, hey, I want
you to cache all of these
things so that they're
available any time I want them.
Now in a real implementation,
don't use this code
because I'm not
catching any errors.
So you definitely want to put
some error handling in here
and do that kind of thing
so if something fails,
you don't have a total,
utter, complete meltdown.
Now finally, once
everything has been
added, we want to
call self.skipwaiting,
that thing to say,
hey, service worker,
take over control right now so
that any other requests that
come through are handled
by the service worker.
Now there's one other thing
that I want to point out
is that I've wrapped
this whole code
block in an event.waitUntil.
The event.waitUntil tells
the service worker hey,
I want you to go do some
stuff, but don't shut down.
Don't go to idle or
terminated until after you've
finished this work, because it
would kind of suck if you were
to say, hey, go
download these files,
and then the service worker
starts downloading it.
Yay.
And then all of a sudden
it gets shut down.
That kind of
defeats the purpose.
So event.waitUntil makes
sure that our service worker
wraps doesn't shut down early.
Then, once everything
has been cached,
our Service Worker goes
into an activated mode.
All right.
So I like to use the activated
event as an opportunity
to clean up the cache.
Is there anything
in the cache that
may be from a previous
version of the service worker
that we want to get rid
of or anything like that?
So removing outdated resources.
So here I've got my
serviceworker.AddEventListener,
and I iterate over a
list of the key names.
So I do cache.keys, which gives
me the key names and iterates
over them, and checks to
see if there's any in there
that we don't want
and deletes them.
So that way we've
gotten rid of anything
that doesn't matter anymore.
Now there's one
other thing that we
want to do in this
particular case,
and that's calling
self.clients.claim.
You can see on the
very bottom there.
And that tells the browser that
we want this service worker
to take control of any
other browser window
that the service
worker controls.
So in this particular
case, we're
not going to worry about
file versioning or anything
like that.
We want it immediately
to start taking control.
This only works if
your service worker--
if you haven't made major
changes to your content.
But at this point, if you
were to go offline, wah wah.
You still get the
dreaded dinosaur.
We've cached all the files,
the resources we need, locally,
but we don't have a way to
get them out of the cache yet.
So we need to do an event
handler to be able to do that.
And we're going to use what's
called the fetch Event Handler.
So the fetch Event Handler works
exactly like you think it does.
Self.AddEventListener.
That self just refers
to the service worker.
It's kind of like this
in the global scope,
but self.AddEventListener fetch.
And it listens for
any network request,
whether it's an XHR,
an HTTP request.
However you're out there
trying to get the file,
it sits there and
goes, oh, hey, I'm
going to intercept that
before it goes out.
And it allows you to
do whatever you need.
So in this particular case,
we're going to say, hey,
do we have anything in our
cache that matches this request?
So caches.match(e.request).
Is there anything there?
Well, if there is,
let's return that.
So it comes immediately
from the cache.
Didn't go to the network.
It just pulled it
straight out of the cache.
But if it's not
there, perform a fetch
and just go get it
from the network.
So in this particular
case, we've
gotten the resources we
need from the network
or from the cache.
So we now have an experience
that loads almost instantly.
It's reliable because
we've got all the resources
we need on our device.
Doesn't matter whether
we're online or offline.
It loads extremely
fast because we've
eliminated any potential
network latency or network
nonexistence.
Our last step is to let the page
know that the service worker is
registered and ready to go.
This is helpful to
indicate to the user, hey,
this app will work offline, or
we're ready to work offline.
So in this particular
case, I'm just going to--
I guess I won't
show you that code,
but you'd just do some kind
of little toast on the page.
Now earlier I mentioned
something about scopes.
One of the cool things
about service workers
is that you don't need
to register a service
worker on every single page.
You only need to register
it once for a set of pages.
And anything within the scope
that it was registered for
will be handled by
the service worker.
Now the easiest way
to define the scope
is simply where the service
worker is served from.
So in this particular case,
I'm serving this service worker
from the root directory.
And that's where I recommend--
very, very strongly recommend--
you serve your
service worker from.
This means that
every resource that
is requested across my
entire site will be served
or will be handled by
the service worker.
Now I made a mistake
many moons ago
when I first started playing
with service workers.
I put my service worker
in a scripts directory
because that's where you put
your JavaScript files, right?
Well, in this
particular case, that
means the service
worker is only going
to handle any files served
from the scripts directory.
And most of my app is not
in my scripts directory.
It's in the images, it's in the
CSS, it's in the root folder.
It's in all sorts
of other places.
So in this particular case,
using the scripts directory,
don't do that.
I beat my head against
a wall for many hours
because I couldn't
figure it out.
I don't want you to
have the same problem.
So don't make the
same mistake I did.
Put it in your root directory.
So the magic of service workers
is that you're in control.
You can say, I want
these things to be
served in this
particular way and how
it's controlled by the user.
I've shown you a strategy
called cache first
with network fallback,
because it went to the cache
first to get the resource.
If it was there,
it returned that.
If not, it went to the network.
It provides a nice fast,
reliable experience for users,
but there are other
caching strategies.
And you're going to
need to evaluate,
on your app, which caching
strategy you want to use.
And you may need to use
different caching strategies
for different resources.
So let's take a look at some
of the different caching
strategies.
So cache falling
back to network.
So this is the one
that we saw earlier.
Up to the network, OK, back.
So network falling
back to cache.
This one is kind of interesting.
This one goes to
the network first,
sees if it can get there.
Now this is something you
would use for data that
needs to be always up to date.
But there's kind of a bad piece
of this in that the browser is
going to wait 60 or 90 seconds
for failure of the network
before it goes to the cache.
So in this particular case, it
can be a frustrating experience
for the user because the
network takes so long
they don't see anything.
So this one, use with caution.
Cache, then network
makes two requests.
So it goes both to the
network and to the cache.
The idea is to show the
cached data first and then
update the screen, or update
the user, with the latest data.
This one is really great.
Think of this.
Most apps do this today.
If you open up your
app, it shows you
the last data it had,
and then all of a sudden
it shows you new data.
So sometimes you can
just replace the old data
with the new data when
it arrives, for example,
a game leaderboard.
But that can be disruptive
for larger pieces of content.
If all of a sudden you're
showing a whole new series
of news articles, and
the user was looking
at a bunch at the top,
and all of a sudden you
shove them all the way down,
that's not a very good user
experience.
So think about how you want to
behave with the user experience
in that particular case.
The generic fallback
strategy, a request
is first made to the cache.
Let's see if it's there.
No, not there.
Let's go get it
from the network.
No, OK, not there.
So now we're going
to go to the cache
and just get a generic response.
This is ideal for
secondary images.
Think like a user's avatar.
You try and get
the user's image.
Well, get it from the cache.
No, not there.
Get it from the network.
Well, we don't have
a network connection.
Well, we'll just show
the little blue head.
That's the idea there.
My favorite use for this is
there's a newspaper in the UK
where if you try
and go to their site
and you're offline,
instead of showing you
the offline dinosaur, they give
you a crossword puzzle to play.
They give you a game so
you stay on their site.
And then once you get a
network connection again,
the site reloads and
you're good to go.
So they've kept you
there and they've
given you something fun to do.
So this is a good use
of the generic fallback.
Now the last one I'm
going to talk about
is cache and network race.
With some combinations of older
hard drives, virus scanners,
some mobile devices, and
faster internet connections,
the network can
sometimes be quicker.
This is rare, but it
does happen sometimes.
So in this particular
case, you want
to get whichever
one comes first.
If you don't really care whether
you're getting the latest
data from the network
or something like that,
this is a really good one to
use in that particular case.
However, going to the
network when the user already
has the content on
their local device
means you're using
extra network data.
And one of the cool things
about progressive web apps
is that they don't use
all of your network.
They're much smaller
in terms of size.
Of course, there are a
number of other strategies
that you can use.
Cache only, where you
just go to the cache.
Network only, where you
just go to the network.
Service worker templating.
I always mess that those three
words up when I say them.
Service worker templating, where
you build your own content.
So you take your HTML,
you grab up some data,
put it together, synthesize
your own response.
But the point here is that with
all of these different caching
strategies, you are in control.
You have the ability
to choose how
you want to respond, with
what particular data, at what
particular time.
They're really powerful for this
and allow you to really build
a networked experience that
is reliable and fast and
consistent.
It just works.
Now because you have so much
control over the network,
it can kind seem daunting
because oh, all of a sudden
now you have an
extra layer of cache.
In the past, if you're testing
something on a remote server,
you might just be dealing
with your local device.
Maybe there's a proxy
server somewhere up
in the cloud that's
proxying stuff and caching
some old data.
Or maybe there's
something somewhere else
that's caching stuff,
and you're going,
why am I getting the old stuff?
Well, with service
workers, there's
even more of a chance
of that happening.
So the development can be a
little bit annoying sometimes.
But there are some
good tools to help
you build better experiences.
So we'll have references to
these at the end of the slides
so that you can have
a look at those.
So don't worry about scribbling
down any of the URLs.
Or you can just go grab a
screenshot like everybody
has been doing that.
So the first one that I want to
talk about is Chrome Dev Tools.
Chrome DevTools have
added a new set of tools
to really help you dive
in and understand what's
going on in service workers.
In the DevTools you'll
find this new application
pane that allows you to
see a number of things.
So it lets you see what's
going on on the manifest,
inspect the service
worker, unregister it.
You can force it to update,
simulate offline behavior,
and more.
Now I'm going to do a
talk later this afternoon
on using these tools.
I'm going to show you some
much more in-depth examples
of using them.
But the Chrome DevTools
is one really great place.
Now of course, other
browsers obviously
have a good set of tools.
Firefox and Opera have
a similar set of tools.
I'll admit it.
I work on the Chrome team.
I'm going to show
you the Chrome tools.
But Firefox does have tools
for debugging service workers.
So does Opera.
And I have no doubt
that Microsoft
will have some fantastic tools
for debugging service workers
when they ship service workers
in Edge in the near future.
So that ability to be able
to debug them is there.
The DevTools not only
allow you to inspect--
let me try that again.
The DevTools allow
you to inspect
not only things and
your service workers,
but also what's going
on in the cache.
So you can see what's
been cached on the device.
You can understand oh, hey,
I thought I cached this.
Oh, there's an old version.
Or maybe there's
multiple versions,
and when we try and
request it, instead
of serving the latest one,
we're serving some previous one.
So the ability to be able
to go into the cache storage
and see what's going
on is really important
and very helpful.
Now in the past, we used
to tell people or recommend
that when doing any work
with service workers,
you used an incognito window.
You opened up the
browser and you
did your experiments, your
tests, your development
in an incognito window.
And then you closed that window
and you opened a new one,
and you did more tests.
And the reason we said
that was because when
you close the incognito
window, everything is deleted.
Your service workers is blown
away, anything in the cache
is gone.
You're starting
fresh every time.
But there's a new tool that
makes this much easier.
In this application panel, you
can go to this Clear Storage.
And I know it's
really low down here,
but there's a button
way down here.
It says Clear Site Data.
I love that button.
It blows everything away.
I use it a lot.
That button will be probably
your best friend as you're
developing service workers.
We have-- if you go to
the developers.googl
e.cn/web/fundamentals, we have
a code lab that will walk you
through some great tutorials
on how to debug these.
And you'll use
that button a lot.
It just blows everything away.
It means your service
workers are gone.
You can start fresh.
You don't need to
fight with anything.
You won't bang your head
against your desk, mostly.
All right.
So the next thing, we've got
a couple of tools or libraries
that you can use to speed up
the development of your service
workers.
So the first one is
Service Worker Toolbox.
And Service Worker
Toolbox is a library
that comes with a number
of pre-built caching
strategies already implemented.
So you can say, hey,
I want these files
to be networked first and I want
these files to be cached first.
And if you're
familiar with Node.js
and routing frameworks
for URL interception,
you're going to be
right at home with this
because it provides a nice,
easy level of abstraction.
And you can just do a search
for this to find this.
Sw-toolbox is the
easiest way to find it.
Here's how it works.
In your Node.js-- let
me try that again.
So if you remember your
cache first strategy earlier
that we showed with all
that stuff where, hey,
is it in the cache?
Is it there?
That was a pain.
This, we can just
say, import scripts
toolbox.router.get anything.
We just provide that URL, the--
wow, I'm totally messing.
A regex.
Thank you.
OK.
I'll try that again.
Provide a regex with URLs
that we want and say, hey,
I want you to go do cache first.
The other one is something
called sw precache.
Sw precache can help you
by literally writing out
your service worker
code for you.
Now one thing that I
will definitely say.
Using something like
this is amazing,
and absolutely this
is the way that I
would recommend doing it.
When I showed you the code
for writing your own service
worker, there were some
dark and scary corners
that I didn't talk about.
How do things get updated?
How did things get versioned?
How do you deal
with lots of files?
In the way that I showed
you, if you change one file,
the service worker has to
re-download everything.
And that's kind of dumb.
If you changed one
file, you should only
have to download that one file.
So using these libraries
are a good way to say,
I just want to do
it the smart way.
Now if you don't want to use
these libraries, that's cool.
But just take a
look at how they've
implemented these things so
that you can understand some
of those dark, scary corners,
and you don't paint yourself
into something bad.
Sw precache is a
node module that you
can use in JavaScript, in
your JavaScript build scripts.
So if you're using Gulp or
Grunt or something like that,
you can use sw precache.
Here's how you would use your
sw precache as a Gulp task
or in a Gulp task.
You just say, hey, write
this, service worker.
I want to precache the files
that end in HTML and CSS.
And I want to runtime cache a
whole bunch of other things.
I want to do fastest for one.
I want to do network first
for some other things.
And allows you to really
just easily define everything
right out of the box.
So I hope I've
given you at least
a good introductory
understanding of service
workers and how they
can be used to build
those reliable, fast experiences
so that your site works
without having to go and fight
with anything so that it just
provides an awesome experience.
We're going to talk more about
some service worker stuff,
because service workers power
a number of other things,
throughout the rest of the day.
But this, to me, if there's one
thing you walk away from today
with, go play with
service workers.
They're the coolest
thing the web has
done since Ajax, in my opinion.
So with that, I
will say thank you.
And I think we will go
to a couple of questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
First of all, you
said [INAUDIBLE]
is supported by OS so that it
has the minimum version of OS
like Android.
The second question is, can
[INAUDIBLE] cache a response
from API like [INAUDIBLE]?
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So the first question was what
was the minimum OS that needs
to support service workers?
And that is, it really is
just up to the browser.
That is the key thing
that the browser has
to support, service workers.
So Chrome, I want to
say it was mid-forties,
started supporting
service workers.
I don't know what
version of Firefox,
but it's reasonably
widely supported
in the mainstream browsers, and
it's coming to other browsers.
The second question was,
can you make a cache
or do anything
with API endpoints?
Absolutely.
The fetch and cache will
handle any HTTP requests
that you throw at it.
So if it's JSON, if it's
an image, if it's SVG,
if it's HTML, Css, JavaScript.
Whatever you want.
You can do that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I have a question
about the availability.
So once you know about
availability, like
is it available on Android?
Is it available on iOS?
Is it available on
any like browsers?
Is it available on Chrome
or Firefox or anything?
And there is one
important thing which
is very popular in China
and the development
for it is very important.
And it's available within
the browser of WeChat.
Thank you.
PETE LEPAGE: So where
are service workers
supported today?
So today, the ones
that I can confirm
that I've tested myself, Chrome,
Firefox, Opera I have tried.
Microsoft has said we are
going to support this,
so Microsoft in
Edge will ship this.
Safari has given indications
that they will support it,
but they haven't said yes.
They haven't given a timeline.
So we don't know when, but we're
pretty sure it's going to come.
Please politely ask
them to support it soon.
Then beyond that, we have had
discussions within the team
with other browser vendors.
They are looking at it.
The thing about
service workers is
they are progressive
enhancements.
So even if you go
and build a site
and a browser
doesn't support it,
the user will still get a good
experience when they're online.
When they're offline,
they won't get it.
The sort of second
piece of that,
I would ask you to do
the same thing that I
asked you to do to Apple.
Please go politely ask
other browser vendors
to support service workers
because we need more folks
to support this.
I think we will see it.
We just need more folks
like you asking for it
and saying it's important.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Quick follow up.
So is it supported by the
browser, not the system?
PETE LEPAGE: It is a
browser-specific piece, yes.
So the operating
system doesn't matter.
So on Chrome, it works
on Mac, on Windows,
on Android, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: Service workers
seems to be a very cool thing.
And my question was, can
we use service workers
with, for example, PhoneGap
or any other cross-platform
application development?
And I have a second
unrelated question.
If I use Google Chrome
for development,
is it that Google collects
anonymous data about my usage
of Chrome or things?
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So first question.
Wow, I just totally
blanked on it.
First question, could you--
hi, my name's Pete.
Whoops.
AUDIENCE: So my first
question was, can we
use are these service
workers available for--
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, PhoneGap.
Yes.
So can you use service workers
within something like PhoneGap
or other cross-platform
sort of frameworks?
And the answer to that is maybe.
But why would you, because
at that point, with PhoneGap
or whatever that
particular case is,
you can already cache those
within the app itself.
The cool thing that
service workers
give you is the ability to say,
I don't want to use PhoneGap.
I want everything to
just work offline.
I don't want to have to go
anywhere else for my user
to get this.
I just want to stay
in the web platform.
The second question
about what is
Google collecting when
you're using Chrome.
I don't know everything it does.
There is a checkbox
that says, hey,
I want to send
anonymized usage data.
You can uncheck that and Google
doesn't collect anything.
What it does
collect, I don't want
to go into that
because I don't want
to tell you the wrong things.
It's not collecting
anything other
than anonymized usage data.
We don't want to
know things like,
are you using service workers?
Are you clicking on
that button, et cetera.
And I think we will--
I know we will run out
of time for questions.
We do have the web booth.
And there are a bunch of us
hanging out at the web booth.
So if you don't get all of
your questions answered today
during the talks,
please come and talk
to us in the web booth, or after
the talks, between the talks.
We would love to answer
all of your questions.
We just don't always
have the time.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi, please, this is
[INAUDIBLE] from Microsoft.
And in your previous
talk you have
said if the service worker
is enabled in the browser
and all the ATP requests
will go to the cache
first and then the
internet, and your cache
will be updated later, right?
PETE LEPAGE: No.
Sorry.
To be clear, that is up to
you in your service worker
how you want.
So in the service worker, when
you capture that fetch event,
you can choose what
you want to do,
whether you want to go to
the network, go to the cache,
or whatever.
That is totally up to you
how you respond to that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I get it.
And my last question is
that some ATP requests
can be responded within
one second, for example.
Could we decide the caching
strategy by latency?
PETE LEPAGE: By latency.
You probably could, though
essentially, at that point,
you could just--
yes, you absolutely could.
You could set a time out
in your service worker
to say, hey, go get this.
If you don't respond
in one second,
give this from
the cache instead.
AUDIENCE: So we could definitely
define our [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
The best thing about
service workers,
you are in total control.
You get to choose
exactly how you want.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
AUDIENCE: I heard
from you that you
recommend the service workers
script our server and root
directory.
That means I must
have this rule.
I have no choice to
upload my service worker
script to the CDN, right?
Thank you.
PETE LEPAGE: So
you can technically
put the service worker
in any directory you want
and force a scope onto it.
So there's a number
of things that you
can do to say, even though
it's served from scripts,
the scope is something else.
So you can override
where it's served from.
But when you do that, you're
diving in deep to some things
that are easy to goof up.
So I recommend always serving
from the root directory.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
So I think we'll wrap up.
Yes?
We'll hang out.
Please come ask us questions.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]